[Applause]
the AGT finals were lit last night and
I'm backstage with the night standout
plus his maroon 5 headed to the Super
Bowl the daily Danny is back to its
regularly scheduled programming now that
the Emmys are out of the way and thank
goodness because it is the last week of
America's Got Talent
and if the performances from last
night's finals are any clue America has
a tough decision guys it's hard for me
to even predict who will win but for
some of these acts win or lose their
lives are about to change case in point
Michael Ketterer father of six closed
the show with an emotional cover of
ain't no mountain high enough his story
has touched America and moved Simon to
put his money where his mouth is I'd
love to be able to give your family the
million dollars and a
what would it mean to get a million
dollars from Simon Cowell I mean no I
can't I can't believe it this is it's
just good if that wasn't enough a
special call-out from Simon Garth Brooks
to write a song for Michael Garth even
invited him to join him on stage at his
Notre Dame Stadium show you've already
won man I know I've been one thing after
the other and now you're going on to
performer Stadium show with Garth Brooks
I know a pinch me yeah are you for that
I'm beyond stoked for him to write this
song literally felt like he like he
wrote he took like from the words out of
my mouth and put them into this song and
it's such a special song that I honestly
I think it sums up my whole experience
really Michael will perform that song
from Garth Brooks tonight during the
finale all right but another standout
from last night our girl Courtney hadwin
she's been a viral superstar from the
beginning and the fourteen-year-old
brought everyone to their feet last
night but was it enough to put across
the finish line
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
I always say the most important part of
being a star is being remembered and
that's what you do every time you
perform people are gonna remember you
you're gonna inspire people you can
you're gonna tell a whole new generation
of people what rock and roll is all
about this was a big performance for you
tonight obviously that it's finale week
how would you describe how you're
feeling in one word crowd have you given
any thought to how you would spend that
million dollars if you were lucky enough
to win tomorrow night everybody's
amazing and unique in their own way
win or lose something major is gonna
happen to you what's next what do you
hope is next after this year I really
want to be able to release my own music
and show people my own music and
hopefully be able do conflict some live
shows maybe have to Greek Theater I mean
are you gonna miss La in Hollywood yeah
you're looking at now that I've visited
all these iconic locations where a lot
of your icons started you're like I want
to be here too do you think your family
would be willing to make the move with
you all right we'll find out who takes
that million-dollar prize when AGT
crowns a new winner tonight and whoever
wins will actually join us live right
here tomorrow at 10:00 a.m. Pacific I'm
so excited
why I'm just like all right now on to
the news that has everyone buzzing and
no I'm not talking about my camera
avocado chores birthday I'm talking
about maroon 5 they're in talks for the
Super Bowl halftime show the source
tells ET room 5 has always wanted to
play the Super Bowl halftime
in fact we're told it's one of Adam
Levine's biggest goals
Adam practically campaigned for the epic
gig on Howard Stern in 2015 when the
band was rumored to be in the running
for half time I know that we're like
probably on a short list
we very actively want to play the Super
Bowl NFL isn't confirming but get this
there's a very big gap in the band
schedule in the beginning of February
which leaves them wide open to perform
at Super Bowl halftime all right but it
is maroon 5 for the big show are you
guys into it or not and what songs do
you hope is on the Super Bowl
setlists let us know in the comment
section and I'll be back here tomorrow
for our live interview with the AG T
winter 10:00 a.m. Pacific please come
it'll be a lot of fun I'll see you guys
tomorrow